[Musique]
bonsoir baratte up en khâgne à merci
d'être avec nous des restrictions depuis
le 27 janvier + port du masque en tout
cas pas obligatoire télétravail qui
n'est plus officiellement recommandé le
pass sanitaire qui n'est plus imposées à
l'accès aux boîtes de nuit ces nouveaux
allègements sont ils pour vous des
décisions politiques où sont-ils
vraiment justifiée par la situation
sanitaire
d'abord je pense qu'il ya un peu des
214 le souligne me connaissent un
passage en conseil qui ont été données
au premier ministre d'origine s'adorent
mais les indicateurs montrent que le
royaume uni se remet d
de l'important nombre de cas d' qu'il a
subi
malheureusement des gens meurent encore
mais en général pour le moment le
royaume uni est en passe de se remettre
de l'explosion des cas alors la dernière
mesure en vigueur tout même d'isolement
des cas positifs qui pourrait bien
sauter bien plus tôt que prévu c'est en
tout cas le souhait de boris johnson
qu'en pense l'épidémiologiste que vous
êtes
concentré ce qui pour nous
être contaminées sans avoir besoin de
s'isoler cela signifie qu'on peut sortir
de chez soi on peut rencontrer d'autres
personnes et concours et donc contaminés
gravement d'autres personnes à rich and
infectious disease et puis des murs en
tant qu'idéologie state experts des
maladies infectieuses je lui conseille
si vous êtes malade si vous êtes
contaminé de ne pas sortir de ne pas
risquer de contaminer d'autres personnes
il vaut bien mieux rester chez soi
plutôt que sortir même si le
gouvernement dit que c'est possible
beaucoup d'observateurs en tout cas
n'ont pas manqué de reprocher ses
décisions boris johnson a pour des
raisons plus politiques on sait que le
premier ministre britannique est empêtré
dans son scandale du du parti gates est
pourtant une stratégie qui s'avère
payante au royaume uni ils leur montrent
un petit peu en popularité malgré tout
la popularité restera toujours fonds
temporaire whitson car on ne peut pas
tricher avec la science vinci ainsi la
science carrefour si l'on est pas free
doses
pour apaiser des maladies cela pourra
déboucher sur des décès
les indicateurs il montre qu'il faut
rester prudent même si le gouvernement
dit qu'il est temps d'abandonner les
restrictions il abandonner les règles je
sais en tant qu'expert des maladies
infectieuses
d'être très prudent tout d'abord il fait
ensuite de ne pas risquer de contaminer
d'autres personnes
si l'on compte années de rester chez soi
puis dans les 4 par exemple des ehpad
les hôpitaux par exemple en tant
qu'infirmier il faut être
particulièrement prudent et continuer à
porter le masque aujourd'hui en france
les restrictions s'allège aussi ce sera
le cas à partir de demain mais dans le
même temps les conditions d'obtention du
pass maximale se durcissent on a réduit
le délai entre les doses de rappel est
ce que en tant que spécialiste de la
question c'est une décision qui vous
paraît justifié aujourd'hui
bustos eu and protect you le rappel
vaccinal protège l'individu des
approches
c'est un choix personnel plutôt qu'un
choix publics
il fait chaud en général mon avis
d'experts de twitter et 9 vac sûr est
que maintenant que nous avons assez de
doses pour vacciner le métier avec les
autres groupes tels que de gâtebourse
est une bonne chose que tous les gens
ici de se faire vacciner de croire il se
rappelle
tous les jours je vois des personnes
en bonne santé
être contaminés et développer des formes
graves de la maladie
se prendre ce rappel c'est une façon de
l'éviter dernière petite question après
chypre c'est au tour du royaume uni chez
vous donc de signaler un premier cas du
delta kron alors cette forme hybride des
variants deltalyo micron il a été classé
dans la liste des mutations sont
surveillance vous pouvez nous en dire
plus combien de cas est ce que cela vous
paraît de nature dangereuse
on
ne sait pas à ce stade si ce variant et
quand je repose mais cela est encore une
fois un exemple du fait que de nouveaux
variants préoccupant ils continueront
d'arriver et cela pourrait être un pas
dans la mauvaise direction et c'est à
dire qu'il pourrait plus contourner
l'efficacité des vaccins contourner les
défenses immunitaires de la chose la
plus importante que celle ci est donc
monté les cas dans le monde entier y sus
sinon on diminue le nombre de cas alors
on espère et j'insiste on espère qu'il y
aura moins de variants préoccupant qui
peuvent apparaître dans toutes les
régions du monde merci marathon cagnard
d'avoir été avec nous pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir